sie haben gerade angesprochen
grundrechte zurückbekommen der deutsche
ethikrat hatte gestern angedeutet oder
klar gesagt dass in zukunft wenn mehr
geimpft und die zahlen weiter sinken
dass der inzidenz wert diese gewürfelte
50 die politisch festgelegt worden ist
weil die deutschen gesundheitsämter
immer noch nicht mehr können als sie vor
einem jahr konnten dass der dann nicht
mehr die entscheidende größe sein dass
sondern die krankenhausaufenthalte und
die schweren verläufe frau brooke hat
uns im interview hinterher sogar noch
gesagt also die chefin des deutschen
ethikrates sie fordert eine öffnung
strategie wie kann die für sie aussehen
also wie kann die kerze aussehen die uns
die regierung hinten in den tunnel
stellt zwei aspekte sind in ihrer frage
enthalten zum einen die frage nach der
50er incidents die es wie sie zurecht
sagen politisch gewürfelt
die instanz von 50 eine festlegung der
bundesregierung die hat sie selber
getroffen
da hat sie sie ins gesetz geschrieben
und jetzt wird alles damit begründet
oder auch nicht denn an vielen stellen
sind wir schon unter der 50er incidents
da kommt schon der nächste wert der aber
ebenfalls dann politisch festgelegt ist
dahinter steckt nicht eine
wissenschaftliche erwägung
es gibt auch viele praktika in
gesundheitsämtern die heute schon sagen
dass die 50er incidents nicht in stein
gemeißelt sein sollte weil man je nach
infektionsgeschehen längst auch 100
instanzen pro 100000 einwohner in einer
woche aufklären kann weil es eben
digitalisierung gibt oder weil man
unterscheiden muss ob an einer stelle
also stichwort in einem betrieb oder in
einem pflegeheim viele neue
krankheitsfälle auftauchen oder viele
individualisiert gemeldet werden
im übrigen ist die 50er instanz alleine
auch gar kein ausdruck für das pandemie
geschehen
man muss ja fragen wer wird infiziert
viel gefährlicher ist es für betagte
menschen oder gar hochbetagte menschen
als für jüngere wie ist die situation im
gesundheitswesen also die 50er incidents
alleine als steuerung für pandemie
maßnahmen überzeugt mich nicht und auch
international
ich denke an italien beispielsweise ist
man längst auch zu einer anderen an
auf einer feineren präziseren regionalen
steuerung der pandemie bekämpfenden
maßnahmen insgesamt erwarte ich mir in
der kommenden woche von der
bundesregierung dass es einen stufenplan
für eine öffnung gibt ersparen und herr
wir haben hier heute die zahlen
vorgelegt ja mit der mutation gibt es
neuen grund zur genauen beobachtung der
lage aber an vielen stellen im land sind
die infektionszahlen sehr niedrig
inzwischen viel niedriger als das
gesundheitswesen beziehungsweise die
gesundheitsämter brauchen um noch
infektionsketten nachvollziehen zu
kommen sind also längst in der situation
wo mit vorsicht und mit klugen maßnahmen
mindestens regional geöffnet werden kann
der öffentlichkeit ist zugesagt worden
dass mit der nächsten bund länder
konferenz auch über eine perspektive
über einen öffnungs plan gesprochen wird
nichts ist davon bisher zu hören
ich bin sehr gespannt ob die regierungen
ihrer eigenen zusage nachkommen nächste
woche einen solchen perspektiv plan
einen solchen stufenplan vorzulegen
da sieht es momentan aber nicht allzu
gut aus wenn ich richtig informiert bin
gab es eine gab es eine runde der
wirtschaftsminister von bund und ländern
und da ist das thema offensichtlich
ausgeblendet worden was wissen sie denn
darüber ja man hört in berlin dass es
eine wirtschaftsministerkonferenz
gegeben hat und angeblich so ist das was
man in berlin hört haben die cdu
wirtschaftsminister und die
wirtschaftsminister der grünen sich
geweigert über einen antrag zur
eröffnung für perspektiven für
wirtschaft und gesellschaft zu sprechen
dem vernehmen nach wollten die spd
geführten bundesländer und auch die
wirtschaftsminister der fdp genau
darüber sprechen unter welchen
bedingungen mit welchen voraussetzungen
ist wo in welchem umfang öffnung möglich
ist schon bemerkenswert dass die cdu
sich dem verweigert aber insbesondere
wäre es eine frage an die grüne partei
die im bund ja nicht mitregiert warum
nicht wenigstens sie sich dafür stark
macht dass wir über eine öffnung
perspektive sprechen immerhin geht es um
einschränkungen von grundrechten die in
unserem grundgesetz garantiert sind und
da ist es die aufgabe der opposition
alternativen vorzulegen mit denen es mit
milderen mitteln möglich ist den
gesundheitsschutz zu erreichen
wir sind bild und wie ihr liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier und vergesst bitte
nicht unseren kanal zu abonnieren